-Seth, it is so nice to see you.
The audience loves you.
-It's great to be
in front of an audience.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I watch your show all the time
and you don't have --
you haven't had an audience
since the pandemic.
-A week from today,
they're coming back.
-Wow.
-Yeah, it's very exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, are you -- are --
Is it going to throw you?
-Well, here's what I think.
It'll be nice to write a joke,
and then if the audience laughs,
I will think I was right.
[ Laughter ]
And then it will also be nice
if I write a joke
and the audience doesn't laugh,
to be able to think
they were wrong.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah, you know, that's --
That's, I think, where
I'm going to be at.
-Yeah, I think the guests
will enjoy it as well.
-I think the guests -- you know,
I got used to
not being in front of
an audience,
but I think the guests,
when they walk out,
they feel like
they've been scammed.
[ Laughter ]
They walk out and they're like,
"Oh, no, I gave them
my Social Security number."
[ Laughter ]
-"There's no one here."
-"There is no one here."
-You're waving, doing nothing.
-You know what backfired for us?
-Unh-unh.
-You know Wally?
Cue card Wally.
-We love Wally.
-Wally Feresten does
the cue cards for "SNL."
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, there you go.
You know, he -- you know,
out of necessity,
he's just been on camera a lot,
'cause we don't have
an audience.
-Oh, no.
-Straight to his head, Jimmy.
-Oh, you created a monster.
[ Laughter ]
-Half the time the cue cards
don't have the script.
It just says,
"People want Wally."
[ Laughter ]
-He's just giving out
his agent's number
so he can get booked for parties
and stuff.
-He's always been a nightmare.
-Yeah, well, I'll have
a talk with Wally.
-Thank you. If you would,
I would really appreciate it.
-You know what I did see that
you did?
You brought back,
because now bars are open,
but your day-drinking segment.
-Yeah, I went day-drinking
again.
-You went day-drinking
with Lorde.
-I did.
-It was very funny.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How was that to get
back out there?
-It was good. I hate to
break celebrity gossip
because that's never been
what I'm about,
but Lorde is younger than me.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-Is that right?
-Lorde is younger than me.
And when day drinking started,
I was acutely aware of that.
-Mm-hmm.
-And then the more I drank,
the more I thought,
"We're just young people."
[ Laughter ]
"Lorde and I are
two young people."
-"We're the same age."
-"And we can drink what we want.
[ Laughter ]
And it won't matter that I have
kids at home
who are gonna wake up
at the same time
they always wake up."
-Yes, of course.
[ Laughter ]
Well, maybe they'll sleep in
out of nowhere.
-I came home late and was like,
"You guys got to sleep
in tomorrow."
-They go, "No problem, Dad.
Yeah. Of course."
How are old are they?
How old are the kids?
-3 1/2 and 5 1/2.
-Yeah. Oh, my gosh.
[ Audience aws ]
-The best, exactly.
-That's the cutest age, yeah.
-It's so great that
it's just, like,
that is why being a kid
is great.
Just to be those ages
gets an "aw."
[ Laughter ]
If I'm like, "47,"
no one's like, "Aw."
-"Aw." Yeah, exactly.
[ Audience aws, laughs ]
Oh, you did get an "aw."
Actually, yeah, you sold it.
You sold it very well.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I know that you -- we talked
about this the last time --
you announced you're writing
a children's book.
-The cover came out today.
Look at that.
-Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at that.
-"I'm Not Scared,
You're Scared!"
-Yep.
-I love the title.
Was that the original title?
-Originally it was,
"I'm not drunk, you're drunk."
-That is not true.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it was.
And then they said,
"It was funny."
-Yeah, yeah.
That was a funny idea.
Did your -- Did you use
your kids as a sounding board?
-I did. I read it.
Well, first, as I was
percolating the idea,
I would tell it to them
like a bedtime story,
about this bear who was scared
and a rabbit who wasn't.
And I told it the first time.
I was feeling really good
about the story I had.
And my 5 1/2-year-old said,
"That part is too scary.
One part is too scary."
And I was like, "Oh, that's
really good to hear."
And then the 3 1/2-year-old,
who echoes everything he said,
said, "Yeah, that part is
too scary."
And I was like, "You need to
have your own ideas."
[ Laughter ]
-"Yeah, you just heard him
say that."
-Yeah, I don't need it --
I don't need to hear it twice.
[ Laughter ]
I don't need the negative
feedback twice.
[ Laughter ]
He's got a Smithers to his
Mr. Burns, just being a yes-man.
-What are the kids going to be
for Halloween?
Have they decided?
-The 5-year-old wants to
be a sea captain
and the 3-year-old wants to be
a pirate, which is good.
It's thematically good.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But then the 5-year-old keeps
trying to make the 3-year-old's
costume more complicated.
So the 3-year-old will be like,
"I want to be a pirate."
And he's like, "Do you want to
be a pirate or do you want to be
a pirate on a ship
so you can have a boat?"
And I'm like,
"Don't up-sell him."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, he's happy.
Like, "You're not going to
build the boat. Cut it out."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
We're putting an eye patch --
-Yeah.
It's like a guy at an Audi
dealership being like,
"We can get you snow tires."
[ Laughter ]
-"Hey, butt out, buddy."
-"He wants the car."
-Yeah. But aren't you --
aren't you guys --
Are you boat or beach people?
Aren't you a family?
-My wife and her family
are beach people.
-Yes.
-I'm not a beach person at all.
I dislike the beach greatly.
And my kids love it, which is
a bummer, because I go --
I would do anything
my kids love.
-Of course.
-You know?
But at the same time,
if something
traumatic would happen
that would make them not go
or not want to go,
I'd be all for that.
And --
[ Laughter ]
My 3 1/2-year-old has a bagel --
This is a true story
that happened this summer.
I wasn't there to see it.
I'm so deeply bummed that
[ Laughter ]
'Cause he was walking with
a bagel, and from what I hear,
he was,
to put it in nautical terms,
"asking for it."
[ Laughter ]
He was holding a bagel up
like this and a seagull
came down and, like --
like it was a falconry show
at a ren fair.
[ Laughter ]
Just, like, came down
and grabbed the bagel,
and I guess he just, like,
burst into tears, as you would
if you're a 3 1/2-year-old.
I mean, you're walking down the
bea-- I mean, it did seem like
he was, maybe,
being a little show-offy like,
"I got a bagel."
-"I got a bagel."
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I know that.
[ Laughter ]
-But the best part about it,
is now,
he thinks there's
just one seagull.
Like, he doesn't realize
there's different sea--
So every seagull he sees, he's
like, "Don't take my bagel!"
[ Laughter ]
-See? That's how you --
-Yeah.
-So one kid solved.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah. Seth, I'm always happy
when you come on the show.
You're doing such a great job
with the show, buddy.
-Always a pleasure.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congrats.
"I'm Not Scared, You're Scared!"
Check this out, everybody.
Seth Meyers.
Check out his show,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers,"
after us, tonight!